you do you do like a lot of types of
streams right i mean i've seen you do
like drinking streams and obviously doom
and just q and a's
what's like your favorite type of stream
to like kind of do and what's like kind
of like
some of the favorite content that you've
made so far oh well that's a tough one
recently the only time that i have to
play games right is when i stream
so those are always quite fun because i
get to relax and play a video game with
chat which is cool
um but let's see i also really like the
streams where i can just talk
because it's fun just talking the chat
or talking about what's going on with me
etc um i never really run out of things
to talk about
which is something that i always think
is going to happen right yeah i always
think
oh man i didn't come up with some kind
of outline i don't know what i'm going
to do
i don't know what's going gonna happen
if i have nothing to talk about right
that's literally this podcast
yeah exactly somehow someway i always
come up with things to talk about
i don't know how it happens it just does
and then if i crack open a bottle of
wine it's even better
yeah exactly i mean like people always
wonder like why do you guys like drink
so often on the podcast
because otherwise we'd just be like i
feel like we haven't seen
that much we haven't driven that much
recently but i feel i feel like any time
any time i don't know why anytime you
stream and you're like drinking alcohol
people are always afraid that you know
people people go like mom mode where
they're like oh
you seem like you're drinking a bit too
much you better watch yourself
like yes mother i am she's like glad you
guys care you know yeah
but don't worry we can handle our drink
yeah i get a lot of people telling me i
gotta hydrate
hydrate i know i know yeah alcohol is
hydration
i mean it's a fluid yeah sure sure
that's how it works for sure
yeah that's definitely how it works so
keep drinking and don't stop please
please please okay so like
you obviously watch like all you know
your fellow whole life members right yes
um but is there any non-whole live
youtubers you like watching
ah that's a great question hmm let's see
oh there are plenty of indies that i
just casually go and check out every
once in a while
i would say right um but for the most
part the the v tubers that i really
enjoy
like their content etc i i would have to
say are musicians
so i check out their music and that kind
of thing or like watch their shows and
concerts
i actually don't watch a ton of um
actual streams i guess
because i'm just very i'm very busy i'm
so busy all the time
and it's hard sometimes i'll have um
something on in the background while i'm
trying to do more work
and that kind of thing but it's not
always a stream you know
um yeah and i'm also very picky i don't
stick around in streams for a long time
actually i never really watched them
start to finish
right right right yeah so like what's
what's what's what's the life of a v
tuber like like what's what's what's
what does your typical day
look like when it comes to like your v
cheaper work and everything like that
right well of course as i've mentioned
before to many many know that i work
i work three jobs in my existence which
is absolutely crazy when i found that
huh yeah
i work one job and i'm like [ __ ] man
holy [ __ ]
yeah it'd be like that i mean on the
daily i'm swinging my scythe around i
have those scythe swinging lessons right
they're real important
um and i have to do them i i can't just
stop doing them right um it's it's not
something even it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter how successful i am or
how many souls i've taken et cetera how
many rainbows chat has thrown at me
that's something that i can't get out of
uh ever for a while
right um but um
i do those and then i come back to my
apartment and
i stream uh whatever right how you have
the energy to stream
after that it's just beyond me here's
the interesting
thing about what you just said is that i
don't have the energy
now that's where the wine comes yeah
exactly that's why you do so many
drinking drinks
that was a [ __ ]
no because it's insane like it's not
just like you but like
there's so many whole life members right
especially yeah and like other youtubers
who can just stream for like
i already have trouble streaming for
like more than two hours yeah right and
i'm
extremely way more relaxed in my streams
than i am on like the show or like my
youtube videos
and i still can't maintain like after
two hours i'm like i actually like
can't even act like i'm relaxed anymore
like i actually have to just be off
camera now i know on a previous episode
that i said oh man i
you know i hope the card is fair but uh
and that that makes it sound even more
like the cut isn't fair but the whole
life people over there
shortly just want to say i'm watching it
was very mean what you said the cut is
good i assure you and yeah it's all good
just saying i found out it's good it's
good
it's all fine they don't work two jobs
because they're broke
it's because i have to i have to because
it's because they can't
say that is that good
no it's all good